الاتفاق الوحيد الجامع بين روسيا
واوكرانيا بعد ان فرقتهما الحرب سينتهي
بانتهاء يوم 17 من تموز يوليو انه اتفاق
نقل الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود حتى الان
الجانب الروسي هو من لا يرغب في تمديد
الاتفاق فالرئيس الروسي يرى ان الاتفاق
عجز عن تلبيه مطالب بلاده وهي ان تسير
عمليه التصدير الحبوب والاسمده الروسيه
بسلاسه بعد ازاله او تخفيف العقوبات
المفروضه بالنظر الى ان الحبوب الاوكرانيه
نقلت عبر البحر الاسود مع بدء سريان
الاتفاق
المسؤولون الروس اكدوا ايضا ان الباب
مفتوح لاعاده تفعيل الاتفاق ان تحققت
مطالبهم وعلى هذا تستمر جهود اقليميه
ودوليه لاعاده العمل بالاتفاق ومنها تركيا
الوسيط في ابرام الاتفاق بدايه والامم
المتحده المشرفه على توقيعه وتنفيذه
وبانتظار اعلان الروس رسميا عدم تمديد
الاتفاق او عكس ذلك فان شبح المجاعه وازمه
الغذاء خصوصا القمح والذره عاد ليخيم على
ملايين المحتاجين لتلك الحبوب حول العالم
وتحدثت وكاله بلومبيرج عن ارتفاع في قيمه
العقود الاجله للقمح والذره فالاتفاق اتاح
تصدير نحو 33 مليون طن من الحبوب منذ بدء
تنفيذه مطلع اب اغسطس عام 2022
الكميه الكبيره هذه عادت في النفع على 45
دوله مثل الصين واسبانيا وتركيا
كما تمكن برنامج الاغذيه العالميه من
توفير 725 الف طن من القمح لدول تعيش
ازمات مثل افغانستان واثيوبيا وكينيا
والصومال والسودان واليمن فهل سيعود العمل
بالاتفاق ام ان حاله الجمود في اي تقارب
روسيا الاوكراني ستغلق المنافذ عليه ايضا